>> Sean: WELCOME TO
"HANNITY."
A LOT OF NEWS BREAKING FRIDAY
NIGHT.
TWO DERANGED ANGRY LUNATICS
FIGHT IT OUT IN WHAT IS
INCREASINGLY NASTY BATTLE FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC NO NATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP FULLY FOCUS
ODDEN THE JOB, SERIOUS ISSUES.
EARLIER TODAY HE TOURED WHAT
IS THE DEVASTATION SADLY TO
OUR FRIENDS IN TENNESSEE.
MULTIPLE TORNADOES RAVAGING
THE STATE ON TUESDAY NIGHT.
KILLING AT LEAST 25 PEOPLE.
INCLUDING FIVE CHILDREN.
ON THE GROUND.
THE PRESIDENT OFFERED HIS FULL
SUPPORT.
VOWED TO PROVIDE WHATEVER
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE THE STATE
WILL NEED.
AND THEN HE FLEW TO ATLANTA.
WHERE HE MET WITH OFFICIALS AT
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION.
THE C.D.C. FOR SHORT.
THE PRESIDENT’S TRIP TO C.D.C.
MARK WHAT IS HAS BEEN THE
SINGLE MOST AGGRESSIVE AND
MOST THOROUGH RESPONSE.
THE QUICKEST RESPONSE BY ANY
MODERN DAY ADMINISTRATION TO
ANY TYPE OF THE PANDEMIC OR
VIRUS OUTBREAK.
IN THIS CASE, THE CORONAVIRUS.
BUT PREDICTABLY, SADLY, HE
CAN’T EVEN AGREE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM GETTING A VIRUS.
I DON’T THINK THE VIRUS CARES
IF IT’S A LIBERAL OR A
CONSERVATIVE INFECTED.
ANYWAY, THE MOB AND THE MEDIA,
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO THEY DO?
THEY WANT TO USE A DEADLY
VIRUS AS A POLITICAL WEAPON
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
SEEMINGLY ROOTING FOR THIS TO
BE, "TRUMP’S KATRINA."
THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE THAT
THE SPREAD OF CORONAVIRUS IS
THE PRESIDENT’S FAULT.
HE IS NOT DOING ENOUGH TO
PROTECT YOU.
THEY COULDN’T BE FARTHER FROM
THE TRUTH.
IN SPITE OF THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" SAYING IT’S THE TRUMP
VIRUS.
IF YOU FEEL BAD, YOU KNOW WHO
TO BLAME.
TRUMP.
IT’S NOT EITHER.
THE TIMELINE, FIRST IDENTIFIED
DECEMBER 30.
OH, THEY HAD A VIRUS IN THE
WUHAN PROVINCE AREA OF CHINA.
BY THE WAY, AND THEN IT IS
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING PNEUMONIA
SYMPTOMS.
THEN IT WAS JANUARY 7.
WHEN WE FIRST NAMED IT THE
"CORONAVIRUS."
DO YOU REMEMBER THAT?
CORONAVIRUS, THIS ONE IS THE
CORONA VARIATION OF PREVIOUS
ONE.
AND JANUARY 31, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, THEY IN RECORD
TIME DECLARED A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY.
AMERICANS RETURNING FROM MOST
AREAS IMPACTED TO QUARANTINE.
MANDATORY.
MILITARY BASES.
SOLING THATSOMETHING THAT HADN’T
DONE FOR DECADES.
FEBRUARY 2 THE TEMPORARY
TRAVEL BAN WENT IN EFFECT FOR
YOU THOSE WHO VISITED THE
COUNTRY OF CHINA.
UNPRECEDENTED STEPS BY THE
PRESIDENT.
HE MADE THE CALL.
WE NOW KNOW AND THROUGH MY
INTERVIEW AND OTHERS MOST
OFFICIALS THOUGHT IT WAS TOO
EARLY FOR TRAVEL BAN OR
QUARANTINE.
IN THE FOLLOWING DAYS THE
PRESIDENT FORMED A TASK FORCE
FILLED IT WITH THE TOP, THE
GREATEST, THE BEST SCIENTIFIC
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS IN THE
WORLD.
LED BY THE VIRUS PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
ON FEBRUARY 29, THE TEMPORARY
TRAVEL BAN WAS EXTENDED TO,
"ANY FOREIGN NATIONAL VISITED
IRAN WITHIN THE LAST 14 DAYS."
ON THE SAME DAY, THE STATE
DEPARTMENT ISSUED NEW TRAVEL
RESTRICTIONS TO ITALY.
WITH THE OUTBREAK HAS BEEN
FAIRLY LARGE.
AND IN SOUTH KOREA.
ALSO ON THE 29th THE
F.D.A. CUT REGULATIONS TO
ALLOW RAPID TESTING RESPONSE
AND THE CAPACITY FOR
CORONAVIRUS.
MARCH 2, THE PRESIDENT MET
WITH PHARMACEUTICAL EXECUTIVES
WHERE HE LEARNED THAT PHASE I
TESTING OF THIS VACCINE IS
IMMINENT.
RECORD TIME AGAIN.
MARCH 3, THE ADMINISTRATION
ORDERED THE C.D.C. TO LIFT ALL
RESTRICTIONS ON TESTING.
TODAY, THE PRESIDENT SIGNED $8
BILLION EMERGENCY SPENDING
PACKAGE IN TO LAW.
HE EVEN DONATED HIS SALARY TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES TO FIGHT BACK
AGAINST THE VIRUS.
MEDIA MOB WEAPONIZATION AND
POLITICIZING OF THE VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE IS BEYOND
PREDICTABLE AND DISGRACEFUL.
YEAH.
LAST WEEK, BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" SAID IF
YOU ARE FEELING SICK AND YOU
KNOW WHO TO BLAME.
THIS IS THE TRUMP VIRUS.
IF THE DOG BITES THE BEE
STINGS AND YOU ARE FEELING
SAD, IT’S DONALD TRUMP’S
FAULT.
INSTEAD OF WHAT?
WELL, MAYBE COMING TOGETHER
AND PROVIDING YOU WITH TRUTH
AND FACTS.
WHAT HAVE THEY BEEN DOING?
SOWING FEAR, PANIC, DISTRUST.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
LIKE WITH EVERY PANDEMIC.
EVERYONE THE ONE THAT BIDEN
AND OBAMA DID NOT REACT AS
QUICKLY TO AS THEY SHOULD HAVE
IN 2009-2010, THAT WAS H1N1.
BETTER KNOWN AS THE SWINE FLU.
THE CORONAVIRUS IS SERIOUS.
YOU SHOULD BE INFORMED ABOUT
REAL RISKS AND REAL DANGERS.
AS WITH THE FLU.
AS WITH ANY VIRUS.
AS WITH ANY PANDEMIC.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST MAJOR
PANDEMIC, POSSIBLE PANDEMIC TO
IMPACT THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE BEEN IMPACTED FAR LESS
THANKFULLY THAN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
BUT WE WANT A CURE FOR
EVERYBODY.
2009, HERE IS THEIR TIMELINE.
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA.
H1N1, THE VIRUS INFECTED 61
MILLION AMERICANS LEADING TO
13,000 DEATHS IN ALMOST A
YEAR.
SO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE.
AND BY THE WAY, TOOK SIX
MONTHS FOR OBAMA TO DECLARE A
FULL NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
SO FAR THEY ARE AROUND 250
CASES OF THE CORONAVIRUS IN
THE U.S.
250 TOO MANY.
ACCORDING TO THE ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF HEALTH, THE
OVERALL ESTIMATED MORTALITY
RATE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS IS
LESS THAN 1%.
OKAY.
PRETTY LOW.
THE H1N1 IMPACTED YOUNG
CHILDREN.
THIS ONE IMPACTS OLDER PEOPLE
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE MORE
SUSCEPTIBLE WITH THE WEAKENED
IMMUNE SYMPTOMS.
THE ELDERLY WITH OTHER
UNDERLYING HEALTH ISSUES.
WATCH YOURSELF.
>> THE BEST ESTIMATES NOW OF
THE OVERALL MORTALITY RATE FOR
THE COVID-19 IS SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN .1% AND 1%.
OKAY?
THAT IS LOWER THAN YOU HEARD
PROBABLY IN MANY REPORTS.
>> Sean: LOWER THAN WHAT
FAKE NEWS CNN, MSNBC WOULD
LIKE YOU TO BELIEVE PERHAPS.
THE WORLD IS NOT COMING TO AN
END.
IT’S NOT THE PRESIDENT’S
FAULT.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT PUT THE
TRAVEL BAN IN EFFECT, FAKE
NEWS CNN SAYS WE’LL STIGMATIZE
OTHER COUNTRY.
JOE BIDEN SAID THE PRESIDENT
IS A XENOPHOBE.
THEY ARE PREDICTING THE
DOWNFALL OF THE ECONOMY.
NOT HAPPENING EITHER.
IN SPITE OF WALL STREET ALWAYS
BEING JITTERY IT SHOWS THE
FUNDAMENTAL STRENGTH IS AT
ALL-TIME HIGH.
WHY?
IN FEBRUARY WE KNOW WE ADDED
WHOPPING 273,000 NEW JOBS.
CAUSING THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
TO FALL YET AGAIN.